[Music]
I'm looking forward to garnish Euston to
help with FEMA clean up after the
Hurricanes with my family and children
who just goes into what I've spent my
day dealing with today in all honesty
I'm looking forward to getting healthy
and being a sober person again oh so
many things I'm looking forward to
pregnancy hopefully in the future
prosperity and peace
meeting new people just exploring the
world so much hey I am looking forward
to spending the rest of my life with my
beautiful wife
definitely kids and just living a very
blessed and prosperous life
I don't know maybe travel drinking wine
this is a night and watch Netflix a good
meal piling my kitchen delicious beer
the biggest beer they sell is what I'm
looking forward to next I'm in medical
school so I'm really just looking
forward to matching into a residency
program I've given it much thought to be
honest I I'm really rubbish I came I
white anchor the end of her wedding
[Music]
what I'm looking forward to next yeah
driving my convertible home going to
Washington State cruisin see if I can
find an adventure that I want to make my
future girl family
and watching this one grow up
[Music]
I'm looking forward to the holidays and
traditions going on the cruise well I
guess going to a Padres game tonight
coming back to California the weekend
and like doing fun things with friends
looking forward to get my bachelor's
degree in business marketing real estate
school receiving my master's degree in
criminal psychology I am looking forward
to going home and seeing our daughter
well I got a lot of concerts I guess my
next concert - a trip to Japan probably
having my own house right now I'm
looking forward to I really do yeah
[Music]
you
[Music]